okay today I'm going to talk to you
about control of blood glucose now this
is an example of homeostasis now what
that means is just trying to keep all of
the different levels in the body just
right because if anything goes out of
sync gets too high or too low it can
cause big problems also it's important
to know that glucose is a type of sugar
so let's have a look at this example
here now let's say I've got this person
here and for their lunch they are eating
a chocolate bar so here is they're
talking about right here
now this chocolate bar got loads of
glucose in but remember glucose is a
type of sugar so and I'm just going to
draw some of the pathway of that sugar
so this is just showing a little part of
their blood vessels that go between two
different organs but Sween this little
organ here called the pancreas and this
organ much bigger organ over here called
the liver okay so this person is eat and
loads of glucose I'm going to show
glucose in the blood in green to show
that we've got the glucose okay so too
much glucose in the blood can be
dangerous we don't want too much glucose
in the blood so what happens is Pank the
pancreas releases this hormone called
insulin
now insulin is a hormone a chemical
messenger it travels in the blood now
what insulin does is insulin remember
the whole point is it wants to decrease
the level of glucose in the blood
because at the moment it's too high so
what insulin does is it travels in the
blood along with this glucose and when
it gets to the liver what it does is the
insulin allows this glucose to be taken
out of the blood and stored in liver
and muscles so it actually creates this
branch structure here called glycogen so
by taking this glucose out of the blood
and storing it in liver and muscles in
the form of glycogen
we've now lowered the glucose in the
blood that's a good thing okay
so we'll see the counter effect let's
imagine this person here instead they
haven't had any lunch okay so instead
this person here let's have a quick
think about what's going on in their
blood so again we're just worried about
a little part of their blood just
between and we're just focusing on a
little bit of their blood rather between
the pancreas and the liver again now
this person this person hasn't had any
food at all so the level of glucose in
their blood is really really low that's
bad - we don't want remember homeostasis
is keeping the conditions just right so
we don't want the glucose levels getting
too high but we definitely don't want
them getting too low either so this time
instead of releasing insulin the
pancreas releases something else it
releases a hormone called glucagon now
the wave remembering glucagon is this
gets released when all the glucose is
gone glucagon now the glucagon it
travels because it's a hormone it's a
chemical messenger that travels in the
blood it travels in the blood until it
gets to the liver remember the whole
point this time what we want to happen
is glucagon increases the amount of
glucose in the blood so when the
glucagon gets to the liver what it does
is it gets this branch structure
remember the branch structure is called
glycogen and it breaks it down back into
glucose okay now the tricky thing about
this topic is remembering the difference
between glucose
glycogen and glucagon because they've
all got similar names so remember that
glucose that's the sugar that's the
thing which one of control the nice way
to remember glucagon is this is the
hormone release when glucose is gone so
a quick recap apart from that if the
glucose levels get too high in the blood
the pancreas releases insulin which
removes glucose from the blood from the
blood and stores it as glycogen which is
this branch structure here and if the
glucose levels get too low in the blood
the pancreas releases glucagon because
all the glucose has gone this travels in
the blood and it causes the glycogen to
break down and re-enter the blood as
glucose that is how we control blood
glucose thank you